make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob
and we are picking up with avengers vol
7 uh the age of
konchu and this is the return of moon
knight and was probably one of the most
epic returns ever
for a particular character here's the
thing about moon knight moon knight is
one of these characters where marvel
hasn't really been using him very often
and in fact we really haven't seen a lot
from him since the end of jeff lemire's
run now the the importance of lumiere's
run which i don't think we ever really
finished i thought we did
and then people had asked me on twitter
if i was ever gonna finish it and i was
actually streaming on twitch one day uh
twitch.tv slash comics explained
and people were like no man you never
finished it and i was like huh well
that's kind of wild
but uh but nonetheless uh so we need to
finish that at some point but the
importance of jeff lemire's run
is it kind of consolidated all the
different personalities of mark spector
down
into uh and into him basically kind of
coming to an understanding and basically
recognizing his different personalities
and not really curing his mental health
but improving it in a lot of different
ways the the important thing about this
is i'm not gonna do this first part in
the way it was actually written because
i think it's a little confusing here
instead what we're gonna do is kind of
skip forward a bit uh and sort of pick
up with the second part of the story to
a degree but essentially mark spector
had been
experiencing these kind of dark you know
dark visions basically right these kind
of nightmarish visions of like you know
devils
conquering the world and wiping out
humanity and and all that kind of stuff
and his initial thought was that konshu
was the one who was causing it and so he
essentially you know moonai ended up
traveling to the temple of konchu and
then when he got in there
ended up finding out kanchu was
experiencing these same visions as well
of like devils conquering and attacking
and so on and so forth and so seemingly
the two guys started working together
now what it does
is it picks up in kunlun right in the
the temple or against the location
where uh where iron fist danny rand
spends his time when he's not you know
out doing superhero antics and
and one thing to keep in mind that when
it comes to moon knight while he does
have three different personalities right
you got mark spector you got steve grant
you got jake lockley and they all play
different roles right steve grant's the
super super rich one mark spector is the
the mercenary and then jake lockley is
kind of like his cab driver
ear to the ground to find out what's
going on in the street level sort of
persona his powers or his abilities kind
of
expand or get stronger when he's in the
presence of a full moon
now for the most part his powers are not
all that grandiose right it's not like
you know when when you know kind of
bestowed with the abilities of
the khanshu gave him that when he's in
the presence of a full moon he has like
telepathy telekinesis stuff like that
it's really more just like improvements
to strength right he can just become
increasingly stronger the difference
here is that at the moment right now you
have what's called a super moon and this
basically amplifies his powers even
further right so it's almost kind of
like like moonlight hulking out to an
extension if you want to try to find
some you know
in marvel comics uh you know metaphor
you know kind of example for for what's
happening here
but the the funny thing about this is
that he's able to initially and
eventually overcome the iron fist danny
rand and he basically beats this guy
into the ground
and then essentially steals his power
right he uses what's what's essentially
an ankh around his neck and steals his
power of the iron fist
following that he travels to greenwich
village and the sanctum sanctorum of
doctor strange
this is a little murkier here right it's
not nearly as easy to steal this power
as it is with with uh iron fist because
all you have to do is overpower iron
fist instead what you ended up getting
were effectively the priests of of
konchu who were sent there beforehand to
kind of distract steven strange which
allowed moon knight to sneak in and then
of course
hit him with one of the anks and then
steal his power as well right to steal
the power of stephen strange and so in
turn he travels to
hillrock heights in east l.a and then he
encounters doesn't really even have a
direct encounter with robbie reyes and
so much as he basically uses one of the
anks to siphon off and steal the power
of robbie reyes right so basically he
has the power of the ghost rider drives
a car and then kind of you know of
course takes off with it and so
following that he ends up traveling to
wakanda with the intention of stealing
the power of black panther the
difference here
is that with with black panther it's not
as simple as stealing the power of other
individuals right because those powers
are external you know essentially with
iron fist he has the power of the iron
fist but that is a power source that can
be taken away when it comes to
uh steven strange he basically has the
ability to manipulate the powers of
others so with him you're basically kind
of stealing knowledge
for you know you know in effect uh with
somebody like robbie reyes you're taking
the spirit of vengeance away from him
but it's like taking somebody's clothes
or somebody's keys or somebody's car
when it comes to black panther his power
is in his blood and this comes by way of
moon knight presenting a kind of ankh
the same one that he used or at least uh
you know the same kind that he used on
on the other characters that we've seen
so far and it doesn't work
because with black panther the power is
in his blood right he consumes the
heart-shaped earth those powers
merge with his body's physical form and
so the only way to steal the power of
black panther
is to literally take all of his blood
right it's to kill him and take every
ounce of his blood and so that's when
you kind of have this bit of a stare
down here and he says you're going to
have to take all of me
let's go like like take me to konshu and
then we'll we'll figure it out from
there right and so you know
at this point it's not it's really more
black panther trying to understand the
bigger picture right kind of allowing
himself to be captured in order to find
out what it is that mark specter is
doing because by this point
word of what moon knight's done has
reached his ears right stealing powers
of doctor strange of of the rest of the
avengers or at least of
robbie reyes and uh in iron fist he's
like okay so like there's some kind of
treachery of foot there's obviously a
bigger game going on here we got to find
out what's happening now the next thing
is interesting but also kind of cook in
the books
in the sense that with mjolnir because
of the fact that milner is forged out of
uru
it is essentially forged out of what's
moon rock for lack of a better word and
moon knight
being bestowed with the powers of
khanshu is able to manipulate moon rock
i.e he can control mjolnir now this is
kind of jason aaron
making up something on the spot because
a big question to ask here is that if
this was the case
why have we never seen it before and if
i'm being honest i'm not familiar with
any instance whereby moon knight has
been able to overpower
thor's hammer and in fact stop it in
mid-air to control the material itself
now this is kind of an indirect
explanation can magneto control thor's
hammer and using this
it seems that you can if you can control
the properties that make up the hammer
you can control the hammer itself uh and
of course the hammer is made of metal
meaning
magneto controls metal magneto can
control the hammer this really kind of
offers an explanation into how that can
be done uh it's not direct right so you
couldn't really use it as a credible
source you couldn't say like well i mean
you know if you're gonna look at this
and you look at that and using the
transitive property it kind of works it
doesn't really work that way right i
mean when it comes to knowing what a
character can do you really kind of have
to go with like a one-to-one ratio but
in this particular instance
the fact that it's made of mood rock and
because there's a super moon and that it
enhances the powers of
moon knight he in turn is able to
control thor's hammer he uses it to
overpower thor and then he takes it of
course he ends up summoning a whole
bunch of different moons from across the
cosmos you know from from various
systems out there
brings them to earth and then just kind
of pummels thor you know using these
moons and that's basically it right kind
of pulling them together and then
basically crushing thor to a degree thor
of course isn't dead but this is
essentially
what konchu sent uh sent moon knight on
a mission for
what's to overpower the various avengers
the last thing is that black panther
cannot be broken he can't be broken in
the traditional sense which is to say to
have him willingly give his blood over
to khanshu uh and so because of that we
don't
he's more or less just kind of being
held captive the phoenix force still
it still exists out there but it's
currently untethered and then of course
there's the star brand entity now the
star brand as we've seen in previous
avengers videos had bonded itself to a
little kid right to a little girl and
the avengers are just basically
monitoring this this star brand just to
make sure that you know this little girl
doesn't go nuts and wipe out you know
every li
all living things on the face of the
earth but the kind of question to be
asked here is what's the whole
motivation behind this in the first
place
right is it really just devils well if
it's devils that are supposedly supposed
to be taking over everything
then there's only one person to go to if
you're concerned about devils doing
bad things and that of course is
mephisto so they end up traveling to the
hotel inferno now this is where
mephisto's been
since the events of marvel comics
damnation storyline where he was
basically locked here
by steven strange uh this was really
just marvel kind of sweeping mephisto
under the rug and putting him on the
back burner and it was really marvel
kind of saying he's there he's in this
location we'll bring him back at some
point in time use them for some kind of
particular ends uh i wouldn't be
surprised if we saw mephisto in the
marvel cinematic universe uh it kind of
makes sense otherwise
none of this damnation never would have
happened he would just be in the
hellscape somewhere and just kind of
locked away it was also partially done
in order to tell a story whereby johnny
blaise could take control of hell
instead of mephisto right to kind of you
know usurp mephisto's control over this
realm but basically they end up you know
kind of entering into this place right
that uh that using the the power of
stephen strange through the ink around
moon knight's neck that he basically
releases the bars and then in turn he
uses the power of thor's hammer to punch
a hole through mephisto and effectively
kill him right now the funny thing about
this is keep in mind mephisto
is the representation of pure evil but
he's representation of evil in its most
pure sense mephisto can never truly die
but this isn't one of these things where
we're talking about like dark side and
dc comics right like true form dark side
if there really even is such a thing uh
the the idea of that is it really is
just kind of evil incarnate with
mephisto he represents hell lords but
he's not a definitive hell lord meaning
he's not necessarily
satan from judeo-christianity and he's
certainly not the one below all right we
know that the one below all is what what
is in essence
absolute evil in marvel comics if from
what we've seen in in al ewing's
incredible hulk where immortal hope run
is to be believed so mephisto is just
kind of a hell lord who's there but
mephisto's immortality comes in the form
of resurrection or just to say no matter
how many times you kill him he'll always
come back
right so he's not necessarily by any
means gone forever but what this does do
is it really kind of picks up two weeks
after that
and it basically shows that konchu has
used the power at his disposal that was
given to him by moon knight right so the
angst belonging or that
that contain the power of stephen
strange and those different guys to
basically create what's called
thebes city you know that was formerly
on the island of manhattan now here's
the issue with something like this
marvel comics used to be they used to
write their stories in such a way to
where the only time you would see
something like this this significant on
a huge scale is if there was a crossover
now
that was back in the 70s and the 80s a
lot of things have changed right
especially during the late 90s going
into the early 2000s this kind of act
wouldn't normally be reserved for a
crossover back in the day right marvel
used to be very similar to dc dc
wouldn't do this for example right you
wouldn't see something like this you
would see it but you would see it
referenced in other comics you don't
really see a reference to anybody else's
comic right it's not as though we've
been reading swords of x and it's like
meanwhile
in manhattan the entire island's been
turned into a giant shrine for khonshu
the
the egyptian god of the moon like it's
not not really something that you saw
right so it's one of these things where
you kind of have to play it fast and
loose and i and i simply say that
because a lot of you guys are probably
going to ask why haven't we seen this in
anybody else's books
because it's just kind of how things are
being done right like every you know
almost every single individual comic has
its own
major event going on which really is is
one of the things that people kind of
get burned out on right when everything
seems like a big deal
the reality is that when you write what
are effectively villain of the villain
of the week stories people get bored
right so marvel's really just kind of
throwing things to the wall and seeing
what sticks and so far this is kind of
what sticks
and so from there you basically switch
over to black panther and the belief
of t'challa is that moon knight is not
operating of his own accord but he's not
operating of his own mind now
the other part of this is that the
servants of of
khanshu are trying to get black panther
to basically acquiesce right they're
trying to break him they got him chained
up they're basically you know whipping
him with uh with a with basically you
know or at least flogging him right with
these you know these whips to contain
uh jagged moonstones just literally
trying to break this guy down on the
most basic level but as we know with
t'challa the guy never gives up right
like the guy
never ever backs down the willpower of
t'challa is absolutely insane and so
when moon knight shows up here
and it's just you know when t'challa's
like you know why are you doing this
like you know
can't you like you know we have to find
a way to get kanchu out of your head the
response of moon knight is no i've had
these visions of devils
conquering the world uh you know
conscious had the exact same villains
we're working together to save you guys
and we're gonna we need to take your
power in order to do it right so it's
not really as though this is kind of an
evil thing and that's one of the things
to understand about this
right that konchu has historically
manipulated moon knight tricked him used
him for his own ends
but this instance it really is different
here right it really is different in
some ways they're going about it in all
the worst possible ways but it really is
different in these particular
ways but it's really more or less marks
vectors saying look i'm not being mind
controlled
right like i'm doing this of my own
accord like i'm doing this
because i choose to because it's what we
need to do in order to save everyone the
other part of this
is that moon knight uh doesn't fully
trust khanshu and it kind of makes sense
just because of the the shady history
they have together and this comes in the
form of black panther kind of
continually trying to to you know
trying to get him understand none of
this is a good idea right another thing
nothing that you're doing here is
beneficial and so on and so forth
and that's what mark specter says like
i'm not blind to what i've done right i
understand the significance of turning
on people who have
historically been my teammates even if
we haven't necessarily teamed up all the
time and even if we fought before right
like i understand the significance of
what i'm doing and i haven't
given konshu all the powers in my
possession i'm not blindly following
this guy and he basically reveals that
he's in possession of the phoenix force
right like he's got the phoenix force at
his disposal and he ends up revealing
here that of course
he is in possession of he's still in
possession of the ghost rider's powers
right which are not small
and that's one of the things to kind of
keep in mind the ghost rider is one of
these guys where it's so easy to throw
him under to kind of sweep him under the
rug right and to assume
that there's not much the ghost rider
has to offer in terms of abilities right
he's just kind of
a guy who's there uh the cool thing
about ghost rider is he's exceedingly
powerful right like he's powerful enough
to take on
all kinds of different guys and in fact
ghost riders face off against galactus
before
so it's not like it's a really small
amount of power right it's only you
become the ghost rider and you can lift
like three tons
it's not like that right it's it's a
it's basically the power of
a god it's a power of the devil being
used you know for for any number of
goals and achievements or whatever it is
that you want to do the other part of
this is that with the the
binds around black panther kind of been
kind of being weakened when the various
servants come back and come back in with
the intention of literally
trying to break him down again by
whipping him uh he literally breaks out
of his chains and then starts beating
the crap out of them right so like at
that point they they kind of flee and
ask con you to save them now pick up
with iron man
and pick up with carol danvers right
they've got the little kid star brand
with them they're trying to keep this
little kid away from konshu as best they
can but for iron man he sees this as
like a very personal
mission that he has to go on right
because remember when we talked about
the the previous story that we had
of iron man being stuck in the past with
the avengers 1 million when he was
eventually presented with the time stone
by mephisto and mephisto
brought him back to the modern day that
he kind of saw a little bit of these
visions
and so it's this is going to be kind of
an important thing because that's the
role he's playing we'll find out a
little bit more about why that matters
here in a minute
but the the the big thing about this is
that again with mephisto because of the
fact that he always comes back
uh you end up having like these
different iterations of mephisto
manifesting right one who's like a one
who's like a pirate right brandishing
these revolvers with with hellfire
bullets they can pure souls different
things like that just kind of
popping back up here and there and and
it's basically khanshu just constantly
killing mephisto now to be honest with
you guys i don't really believe khan shu
is powerful enough to kill mephisto
right mephisto is
a universal entity he's wildly powerful
you know in
his own way the way in which they were
able to kill him before the longer
mephisto stays away from his realm among
the hell lords the weaker he gets so it
wouldn't make sense like when they visit
him in that cell they could actually
kill him but when he manifests he should
be as powerful as he could possibly be
and that's
no small thing right the sky is nuts in
terms of his power khanshu was never
really being shown to be that powerful
before but he's also a character that we
haven't really seen that much before and
so in a lot of ways uh jason aaron is
kind of flying by the seat of his pants
with the power of the khan she possesses
and what it is that he can do right so i
guess it's kind of believable in that
way because we don't really have much to
tell us that it shouldn't be done but
regardless what khan
has been doing is basically killing all
these versions of mephisto they keep
manifesting right every time one comes
back and there's been you know a little
over a hundred so far every time you
know mephisto comes back khanshu fights
him and then kills him right it's just
kind of been going on consistently
at the same time you've got captain
america you've got blade and you've got
she-hulk who were launching
an effort to find like danny rand you
know the iron fist trying to find steven
strange those individuals whose powers
were taken by konshu and whose conscious
forces had kind of you know
basically taken into hiding or you know
kind of removed them from the landscape
now the reason why this matters is
because in an
effort to entrap the rest of the
avengers the forces of conscious kind of
let it slip that like these guys were
going to be on this train right steven
strange danny ran the iron fist
uh robbie reyes that they were going to
be on this train captain america and his
team took debate and then basically
rescue these guys right that leads to
the forces of konshu showing up and then
all hell kind of breaking loose among
these these various forces here
at the same time that happens uh moon
knight actually ends up going directly
after iron man and carol danvers right
there's a little bit of bickering here
it's kind of funny you know watching
like tony stark who's kind of an idiot
trying to take care of a kid which he's
completely ill-equipped to do
but he recognizes the significance of
this kid and recognizes the significance
of what could happen
if the the the visions of kanchu and
moon knight were actually correct
and so there's a point whereby moon
knight shows up here he captures uh
carol danvers and then goes to attack or
at least goes to try to take the baby
away
from uh from from tony stark using the
power of the ghost rider and then
basically says like like basically makes
mention and saying that like you know
everything that we fought for is going
to die right you have to let me finish
what i started or everything's gonna die
if we let mephisto win
and the fact that he references mephisto
tells tony stark this ties into his
whole experience right and we'll have
that video
down in the description in case you guys
want to get caught up i don't want you
guys to feel left out or anything
but uh but but in that moment because of
the fact that this kind of goes towards
quite literally stopping mephisto and
these kind of devils more or less that
seem to be popping up again we don't
really know if that's actually the case
we're largely just kind of assuming
alongside moon knight and konchu that he
initially was going to give the kid over
to moon knight that in turn
basically leads to carol danvers kind of
freeing herself jumping in grabbing tony
stark and the baby and flying away right
and tony stark's like do not let me near
him again and like do not let me mirror
this baby again like take this baby and
fly away as far as you can right because
if something
like if this happens again i will end up
giving this kid to to moon night right i
don't want to but i'm driven to
right like i kind of have this this
drive to and so of course with black
panther freeing himself
from the various guys who are out there
you know freeing himself from the
priests of kanchu
he goes to basically confront kanchu
himself right to confront this guy
himself now the reason why this is kind
of important here is because
in this moment when moon knight had had
basically kind of been left
right with with carol danvers grabbing
iron man and the baby and then flying
away
that in an effort to kind of understand
whether or not kanchu was telling him
the truth he ended up going to the moon
right for a moment of solitude just kind
of staying there and just kind of
thinking for a minute or two and he's
met by the unseen now for those of you
guys who aren't really familiar with
this guy because it's been a
long time since we really covered him uh
the unseen
is classic nick fury from back in the
day right like old school white guy nick
fury for
that you guys know who he is right you
like here's a picture of what he looks
like of old school nick fury this is a
picture what he looks like you know him
when you see him but the idea was that
during the original sins story arc back
in
2014 or whatever it was it was written
as part of the lead up to hickman's
avengers new avengers and eventually
secret wars um then of course we'll have
that description as well that that whole
playlist
uh my editors whoever this is uh we'll
post this down in the description the
idea behind that was that nick fury had
basically killed the watcher in order to
cover his own tracks for something that
he had done the result of this is that
when it came out that nick ferry was the
one who had done it the other watchers
banded together and then confined him to
the moon
right so no one really knows he's there
i mean some do here and there like
people who kind of go by there happen to
see him something like that but he's
basically confined for
essentially all existence to stay locked
and chained to the moon
and and able to witness everything that
happens on earth but being unable to do
anything about it right now even then
he's still pretty ambiguous i mean it
makes it clear jason here makes it very
very clear nick fury as we knew him
is long since dead and it's basically
just the unseen as he calls himself but
what he basically tells moon knight here
is you've been praying to kanchu
all this time but if you're going to win
this you can't pray to him you're the
only one who can really
end this you cannot pray to to conscious
anymore you have to learn to pray to a
different god and when you do that when
you give yourself
over fully to that god then in turn
you'll possess the kind of power that
you need
in order to essentially save the day and
so what you end up getting here
is is you kind of jump back to black
panther confronting
konchu and ultimately being met by by
moon knight now moon knight had come
back here with the intention of
confronting khanshu himself
but in the recognition that black
panther was here and realizing that with
these two teaming up that most
likely honshu would have to be forced to
flee that this led to khanshu using the
power of doctor strange to trick the
mind of moon knight into believing that
black panther was mephisto and so
literally it's an illusion and so moon
is just fighting against this guy
as best as he possibly can now
ultimately this fight drags on pretty
far
and it's kind of interesting to see this
to be honest with you guys i mean one of
the funny things that happens is that
honshu throws his hammer throws the
hammer of mjolnir uh at black panther
and black panther like
catches it and then just in like
literally shows that like he's worthy of
lifting it the funny thing is he doesn't
use it and that's that's kind of see
that is how it needs to be needs to be
done like in my mind
showing a person's worthy of wielding
mjolnir is one thing but like when you
show they're worthy
and then you in turn use that worthy and
that person picks up the hammer and then
starts fighting it kind of cheapens it
you're like yeah i'm worthy of using it
but i don't need it right like i can
i can do this on my own which is kind of
an important thing right it's a cool
little moment there
because what you end up getting is that
with this illusion being cast
and and moon knight facing off against
black panther black panther tries to
reason with him as best he can
but black panther also ends up putting
the full might of his martial arts
literally on display here right the
flying leopard claw kick the black mamba
spine strike the hippo fist which is
kind of an interesting name for a
martial arts move
but like the fist of khanshu which moon
knight tries to use on black panther and
it doesn't work right he just he just
basically overcomes like one of the
coolest names here
is the rage of mini wildebeest that's an
amazing name for like a for
for like an assault i think it's cool uh
but basically black panther is able to
get the upper hand
on moon knight and then incapacitate him
now the reason why this matters is
because moon knight had long since fiona
realized he was under the spell of an
illusion right that he was under the
spell
of of konshu using the power of stephen
strange and basically says like like you
know you're gonna have to make me bleed
like you're gonna have to like
pummel me you know if if you know if i'm
going to succeed here it's a little bit
ambiguous but we basically end up
realizing that in doing this he's
basically
casting off the influence of konchu and
casting off his faith and belief in
kanshu the reason why this matters is
because it in turn allows the phoenix
force to bind itself to uh to moonlight
now again
the phoenix is part of the original
avengers right and that's really the
power source
that kanshu was going after the power of
all the original avengers right
the avengers 1 million bc that you had a
you had a basically mjolnir which was
being used by uh by odin that you had um
you had the phoenix force
you had the first black panther you had
like the the first star brand or really
the second star brand the first one was
a tyrannosaurus rex but like you had the
second star brand that's what the the
power that kanchu was going after the
power of the original avengers to
destroy whatever threat this was that
was coming towards earth but moon knight
absorbing the totality of the phoenix
force unto himself
and then taking off into space really
kind of changes things because the truth
about this is
this feels like it should be a major
crossover event a lot more significant
than what you would see in a story like
this but at the same time
it is also the avengers comics and under
normal circumstances if we were talking
about the avengers comics 15 years ago
it wouldn't be this big right it
wouldn't be like a massive space-faring
event with like
a person being imbued with the full
power of the phoenix force and then like
going to town on like
an egyptian god of the sun you wouldn't
really see that ever since the marvel
cinematic universe and like the first
avengers movie
there's always kind of been this demand
in comics to to amp things up right to
make like the avengers as big in comics
as they are in the movies kind of this
expectation
that coming from those movies and
sitting down and reading an avengers
comic you're going to see like these
insane story arcs and that's really
where we are now right that's why the
avengers comics are being written this
way
because it's kind of what people expect
after having gone and see the movies
that's one of the drawbacks of the
movies right because you end up
seeing a removal of character-driven
stories and instead it focuses on like
big high-octane action events which
there's not always room to do both
and this one there is but there's not
always room to do both of that across
the board and that's kind of the problem
that you run into
if you have to choose one which one do
you choose but moon knight showing up
here
and beating the crap out of konju after
realizing that he's basically being
manipulated uh leads to of course you
know the the attempt of him to take
the star band child away from from iron
man and carol danvers only to be
declined and then to say okay fine
then get the kid out of here right like
i don't mean any harm to this kid this
kid wants to screw me up and uh the
the whole point of the star brand's
power is to be powerful enough to
overcome
any foe he faces off against hence the
reason why in hickman's avengers and new
avengers one star brand was able to
destroy one beyond her because it was
facing off against one beyond her at the
time
ended up destroying the entirety of the
star brand right he ended up having to
kill himself or at least he was already
dying but he ended up destroying his
physical body
you know in order to actually destroy
that one beyond her but like it would be
enough power to take out mark specter if
that if that baby had full full control
of the star brand's power but the fight
between these two guys where you end up
having you know khanshu basically
knocked back down to the surface the
response of khanshu is to tell his
forces
amass as many of yourselves as you can
right like the full totality of my
forces face off against these guys here
i will deal with moon knight out in
space as best
i can the problem with that is that as
soon as he starts to come too
you end up having the arrival of robbie
reyes and robbie reyes and black panther
end up stealing or end up taking the
angst
of uh of konchu and taking their power
and you know taking the the power from
kanchu and then giving it basically to
different avengers right stephen strange
is still knocked out robbie reyes has
has come to and so you end up seeing
this power being given to like she hulk
who ends up becoming the new iron fist
blade who becomes a new sorcerer supreme
and then of course
robbie reyes ends up getting his own uh
getting getting his ghost rider power
back now it's not going to stay this way
but it is kind of a cool little shift up
you know even if only in the moment to
see this kind of thing go down
the problem with this is that while you
have mark spectre out out you know kind
of hovering above the earth with the
power of the phoenix force he starts to
realize this power
is too much for him to control and it's
literally sending his mental illness
into disarray because remember the
phoenix force really seems to kind of go
nuts
if it starts experiencing emotions or
concepts that it didn't experience
before there was a whole idea behind the
dark phoenix saga the phoenix force
started experiencing jealousy rage you
know different emotions that the phoenix
had never really been never really been
privy to and experiencing those sent it
on this dark and twisted path where like
it corrupted jean grey and just kind of
went nuts
in this instance the phoenix force is
experiencing multiple personality
disorder if it stated it stayed bonded
to mark specter enough it could actually
drive the phoenix force insane but in
this instance mark begins to realize
the phoenix force is making his mental
illness worse and so in order to to
essentially overcome it when
thor reemerges from all these worlds
that have kind of been crushed together
to keep him and keep him held apart to
keep him in stasis he summons his hammer
back to him realizing that his hammer's
close and then like pummels moon knight
and sends him crashing back down to
earth you know he ends up pummeling moon
night the phoenix force leaves moon
knight kind of goes back out does
whatever it is going to do but in that
moment he's more or less defeated
following that you end up having you
know moon night kind of crash landing on
earth phoenix force takes off konshu
wakes up and then conscious in turn
apprehended by the avengers but not
before saying
i did all of this in order to like
protect the world from that threat right
from these devils that are going to
invade you're not going to have the
power for that but the response to the
avengers is then we'll find that power
ourselves right but it's not the job of
some moon god who's more or less you
know kind of gone nuts to take that role
unto himself right like you know even
though he was coming from a place of
altruism
it's not the best thing the other
question that really comes out of this
is
what's going to happen with the phoenix
force if any of you guys had read jason
aaron's
uh basically his thor run you end up
finding out at a future point in time
wolverine bonds to the phoenix force and
that really is kind of what he seems to
be pointing out here right that where
you end up having
jean grey who was kind of watching all
that go down that is kind of like okay
like
something's coming right jean grey
recognizes the phoenix force is coming
again right the phoenix force is out
there on earth and it's looking for a
suitable host and where jean grey says
it's not looking for me then the
response the question is who is it
looking for
and while we're not necessarily given a
definitive answer here it looks like
it's going to end up bonding itself to
wolverine we'll find out whether that's
true or not but that's what it looks
like it's going to do but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like i will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
you